bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct pour commenter donc cette
conférence de presse très importante
jean castets ce premier ministre avec le
ministre de la santé ou libérant
roselyne bachelot ministre de la culture
cédric aussi secrétaire d'état au
numérique des mesures fortes pour ont
été annoncés ce soir il est toujours
possible de circuler pour l'instant sur
le territoire français l'objectif on le
voit bien c'est quand même d'éviter 1re
confinement et surtout de préserver l'a
dit lui-même jean castex la capacité
d'accueil des services de réanimation
dans les hôpitaux
oui tout à fait donc ce couvre-feu qui
s'étend à 38 départements maintenant au
nombre de 54 départements et territoires
d'outre-mer à 21h tout le monde devra
être à la maison et donc tous les
commerces qui vont être impactés
comme c'est le cas dans les départements
déjà touchés par ce couvre-feu
l'idée étant bien entendu d'éviter un
confinement comme ça avait été le cas en
mars tout en gérant le flux de malades
qui auraient besoin de lits de
réanimation puis ce que je dis n'est pas
de multiplier lits de réanimation sauf
si jamais le pic venait à être comme
comme c'était le cas en mars de manière
[Musique]
exponentielle donc tout est fait pour
éviter ce qui est dommage c'est que on
aurait peut-être pu commencer à prévoir
avant cette deuxième vague qui n'a pas
été du tout planifié donc retard à
l'allumage sur les tests etc ce trac et
testé isolé qui a fait défaut à partir
du déconfinement pour que nous arrivions
dans ces mesures de semis confinement
qui sont qui ait le couvre-feu en
réalité parce qu'il s'agit de préserver
le travail autant que faire se peut
durant la journée les mouvements durant
la journée et que la nuit est bien les
les mouvements sont arrêtés et les
rapports sociaux doivent être limitées
là encore tout est tout est niveau de
dosage sur la façon dont les
interactions peuvent être faites compte
tenu du moment difficile comme l'a dit
jean castex les semaines qui vont venir
vont être cruciales pour éviter ou non
un confinement
alors c'est vrai on vous l'avait dit
jean castex qui a bien précisé que les
semaines à venir allait être difficile
que le nombre de décès devrait être
augmenté et que le mois novembre
s'annonce extrêmement éprouvant
c'est un discours qui est à la hauteur
aujourd'hui de la mesure de cette
épidémie vous pensez vous dites que
c'est un petit peu tard aussi l'annnonce
de ces mesures qu'on pouvait faire
peut-être mieux alors on peut toujours
faire mieux évidemment le principe de
cette gestion de crise depuis le début
c'est quand même globalement la
profitation alors on appelle ça
l'adaptation par rapport à ce virus et
par rapport aux réalités donc l'idée est
de coller au plus près aux réalités des
territoires donc à éviter que tout le
monde est ce grand confinement qui avait
été le mois de mars parce que ce n'est
pas forcément nécessaire dans certaines
régions donc c'est la proportionnalité
qui fait la réponse est derrière il ya
bien sûr la question des moyens des
hôpitaux dans chacune des régions plus
l'hôpital est doté plus c'est possible
de répondre plus facilement à l'afflux
de personnes en réanimation mais une
fois encore toute la stratégie est toute
l'idée c'est d'éviter que les personnes
infectées ça
arrivant réalisation et donc éviter le
nombre de personnes infectées tout
simplement donc un traitement en amont
en évitant qui est du contact entre gens
contaminés symptomatiques et
asymptomatiques ou pas pour que le
nombre de contaminés diminue ou reste
stable et qu'on évite de rentrer dans
des cas difficiles en fonction des
pathologies de chacun justement voilà
voilà la stratégie justement sur la
question de la capacité d'accueil en
réanimation dans les hôpitaux on l'a vu
ce qui s'est passé alors au plus fort de
la crise sanitaire au mois de mars et
les semaines qui ont suivi vous vous
croyez qu'on a vraiment tiré les leçons
de cette période pour pouvoir faire
mieux aujourd'hui vraiment pas vraiment
non on voit bien qu'on a l'impression de
recommencer un peu comme en mars avec le
même discours l'idée c'est toujours de
faire peur mais pas trop de
responsabiliser mais avec de la
contrainte donc on est revenu quand même
avec des droits de sortie des
formulaires pour sortir après le couvre
feu
alors c'est un couvre feu c'est pas un
confinement mais voilà c'est c'est la
moitié de la journée qui est qui est
prise par ce confinement de fait mais
sur ce qui est de l'organisation
sanitaire oui apparemment on a quand
même appris un peu à connaître mieux ce
virus donc à avoir des protocoles
notamment réanimation qui sont plus
efficaces et donc qui limite à la fois
le nom deux jours passés en réanimation
et et le risque de décès donc là oui je
pense qu'il ya eu de la part du
personnel soignant un apprentissage
évident pour ce qui est du choix
politiques leur packaging de ce top cow
vite cette application qui maintenant
s'appelle tous antico vide je ne sais
pas si les français vont adhérer à
nouveau
d'ailleurs cédric aulas dit il n'attend
pas le grand soir de cette application
mais simplement qu'il y ait plus d'un
million de français qu'il télécharge que
qu'on commence à avoir une un nombre de
français suffisant pour que cette
application soit utile mais l'utilité de
cette application reste malheureusement
à prouver et puis jean castex qui qui a
fait amende honorable et qui dit cette
fois ci qu'il a téléchargé tous sentis
qu'ovide personnellement contrairement à
téléco vide comme il l'avait appelé
qu'ils n'avaient pas téléchargé parce
que soi-disant lui ne prenait pas le
métro donc là c'est un exercice de
communication auxquels nous avons
faire ce discours la réalité fait que
aujourd'hui le gouvernement essaye de
protéger un maximum les services
d'urgence les services de santé pour
éviter un afflux massif qui ferait que
les hôpitaux soient débordés et on aura
remarqué aussi que jean castex pour
justement faire passer son message
concernant l'application la nouvelle
application tout senti que vite qui
remplace donc cette application stop&go
vide il a aussi appelé à respecter un
certain nombre de gestes barrières qui
l'a rappelé oui alors c'est incroyable
c'est un premier ministre qui fait un
discours et donc il vous explique un
comme comme les référents qu'ovide qu'on
a envoyé aussi dans la rue dans auprès
de populations qui n'avaient pas accès a
forcément toutes les informations et
donc il rappelle systématiquement quels
sont les gestes barrière lors de ses
discours et on voit bien qu'ils se
mettent en scène aussi avec ce masque la
mise la mise en place du gel avant de
prendre la parole donc vraiment l'être
le plus pédagogique possible avec les
français en disant que nous n'avons pas
de solution à part ces gestes barrières
aujourd'hui qui sont la distanciation le
masque ce qu'il a rappelé voilà tout
simplement été remué dans son coude
éviter de se rassembler à a trop de
personnes
voilà parce que le vaccin c'est pas pour
demain même si on n'en parle plus encore
un mort alors dans des essais cliniques
d'un vaccin qui a été arrêté au brésil
rien n'est sûr sur l'efficacité d'un
potentiel vaccins dans les mois qui
viennent donc aujourd'hui la seule
solution qu'ont les états elle et les
différents territoires continent c'est
d'éviter la propagation d'éviter que
cette ce virus soit hors de contrôle
donc essayer de contrôler un maximum 100
m l'économie à terre comme peut le faire
un confinement
une équation difficile à tenir pour
n'importe quel gouvernement
juste pour terminer sans cette
application tout senti qu vite pourquoi
finalement gouvernement n'a pas relancé
à stop coville n'a pas reconnu qu'il
s'est trompé qu'il a fait un faux pas
concernant la mise en place de cette
application
c'est rare que le gouvernement
reconnaisse ses erreurs et ses faux pas
vous avez en ce moment d'ailleurs les
mini
str les anciens ministres qui sont
entendus à l'assemblée nationale sur
cette gestion de la crise sanitaire
edouard philippe sa seule défense c'est
dire je n'étais pas au courant ou je
n'ai fait que écouter ce que les
médecins me disais donc reconnaître une
erreur c'est dangereux pour le
gouvernement compte tenu de la façon
dont va être jugé la gestion de cette
crise dans les mois les années qui
viennent parce qu'il ya eu des erreurs
des erreurs flagrantes de doctrine dans
là l'explication de ce qu'était le mas
de comment ça fonctionnait
l'organisation la non organisation
plutôt au niveau régional de toutes ces
remontées l'a donc aujourd'hui tout est
fait par le gouvernement pour éviter
d'être responsable de continuer d'en
dire le moins possible donc
effectivement dire que stop qu'ovide
coûte trop cher et ne sert à rien c'est
reconnaître encore là une erreur
stratégique fondamentale donc surtout
pas on continue on n'a pas tort on re
package avec un nouveau nom même si
quand vous téléchargez l'application
apparemment certains messages d'erreur
continue de nommer tous sentis comme il
stoppe qu'ovide donc on voit bien que
c'est un travail qui a été fait
vraiment en toute hâte pour proposer une
appliquer exactement la même à peu de
choses près et faire en sorte qu' elle
soit accepter cette fois ci compte tenu
de la deuxième vague mais rien n'est
moins sûr on rappelle donc jean castex
qui a donc annoncé un couvre feu étendu
à 38 départements et en polynésie 21h à
6h du matin pour six semaines à compter
donc de vendredi minuit au total lâché
54 départements 46 millions de français
qui sont donc concernés jean castex
alexis poulain qui parle d'une riposte
graduée et territorialisée c'est la
stratégie aujourd'hui gouvernemental
pour faire face donc à cette seconde
vague de l'épidémie parce qu'on est bien
dans une seconde vague de l'épidémie
aujourd'hui oui elle est nommée comme
tel par les autorités publiques et je
crois que les chiffres aussi le montre
alors attention les chiffres encore une
fois parce qu'on ne parle plus forcément
de la même façon d'aider même cas que
lors de mars puisque en mars les
chiffres qu'on avait c'était en dehors
des tests on avait très peu de tests en
marche noire mars pardon aujourd'hui on
a beaucoup de tests ce qui fait que les
chiffres oui de deux cas avérés qu'ovide
sont énormes et reste que la mortalité
augmente que les entrées en service de
réanimation augmentent également
mais on voit bien que entre le nombre de
cas qui sont affectés et le cas en
réanimation
il ya quand même une énorme différence
donc l'idée c'est de ne pas être trop
rassurant c'est de dire que le virus tue
qu'il est dangereux pour les plus
faibles d'entre nous et c'est vrai qu'il
touche toutes les classes d'âge mais en
même temps voilà de dire voilà la
réalité est telle aujourd'hui qu'il faut
faire attention et donc continuer à
respecter les gestes barrières et les
mesures qui sont imposées par l'état
d'exception qui sont le couvre feu même
si encore une fois
la chaîne des contaminations n'est n'est
pas du tout prouvé on ne sait pas du
tout où on se contaminent si c'est
davantage dans les bars que que à
l'université à l'école ou dans les lieux
de travail
l'enquète est lancée par les services de
santé donc on le saura plus tard mais
c'est tout ce qu'il reste en fait pour
éviter les aléas circulation et le
contact entre des populations non
contaminé des populations contaminées
donc on en est là un peu comme au mois
de mars en attendant de voir si dans
quinze jours il ne faudra pas décréter
comme certaines régions en europe où
d'autres pays européens un nouveau
confinement
c'est justement le mot qui fait peur un
nouveau confinement votre sentiment
là-dessus
vous pensez qu'on se dirige vers un
nouveau confinement finalement si jamais
confinement il devait y avoir ce ne
serait pas je pense à un confinement au
niveau national parce que maintenant
nous avons suffisamment de retours au
niveau territorial pour savoir où le
virus circule le plus rapidement et où
sont les populations les plus soumises à
cette pression du virus donc si
confinement il y aura ce sera je pense
déconfinement de grands centres de
métropole ou des zones où le virus
circule énormément mais je pense pas
qu'on pourra faire et ce n'est pas
souhaitable
un confinement comme ça a été le cas en
mars de toute l'économie du tout le
territoire français ça n'aurait aucun
sens aujourd'hui que nous avons
suffisamment de retours pour savoir où
circule le virus donc s'il ya eu un
apprentissage c'est celui là je pense
c'est d'éviter à tout prix un
confinement généralisée donc mais ça
n'exclut pas des confinement
territoriaux locaux sur peut-être moins
de temps 10 jours quinze jours pour
enrayer la circulation du virus au moins
sur certains territoires où la ces
critiques le confinement c'est un mot
que refusent de prononcer pour l'instant
le gouvernement mais est ce que vous
croyez qu'il se prépare tout de même
à au pire je pense qu'il se prépare à
toutes les éventualités le confinement
est effectivement une de ces
éventualités
tout est fait aujourd'hui pour l'éviter
bien sûr mais mais rien ne dit que il
sera évitables donc c'est le couvre-feu
maintenant c'est davantage de
télétravail c'est réduire les
interactions sociales autant que faire
se peut on est aujourd'hui sur 54
départements et territoires d'outre-mer
en couvre feu ça pourrait encore être
multipliés et puis ensuite
ensuite viendra les confinements locaux
territoriaux si besoin est
mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui le
gouvernement n'enlève aucun scénario de
la table
compte tenu de la difficulté de freiner
la propagation de ce virus de gérer la
propagation de ce virus au niveau
d'ailleurs du continent européen et pas
seulement de la france jean castex il a
précisé que le taux de reproduction du
virus il était là en 35 ans ce qui
signifie un doublement des cars ses 15
ans 15 jours vous parliez des tests tout
à l'heure justement olivier ferrand le
ministre de la santé lui a évoqué le
sujet il a parlé d'une augmentation de
test est effectif à 1,6 million de tests
ces dix derniers jours en précisant un
point très important qui préoccupe
beaucoup les les français c'est le délai
de délivrance des résultats qui réduit
semble-t-il maintenant à 48 heures bon
ça aussi ça a été une polémique raté
aussi pour le gouvernement il ya eu la
polémique autour des masques et les
tests aussi dans les délais de
délivrance c'était problématique
oui alors d'abord ça a été le
cafouillage autour des masques
maintenant nous avons des masques et
puis ça a été ensuite à la rentrée le
cafouillage autour des tests c'est à
dire qu'il fallait testé massivement
mais on avait les résultats beaucoup
trop tard ou bien il fallait attendre
beaucoup trop longtemps avant d'être
testé et puis la fiabilité des tests
aussi qui a été remise en question
donc aujourd'hui nous avons davantage de
tests avec comme le dit olivier vers en
48 heures pour la délivrance des
résultats tant mieux des nouveaux tests
aussi qui permettent d'avoir ces
résultats plus rapidement c'est la
moindre des choses
mais voilà il aura fallu septembre
octobre pour se mettre en route et pour
arriver à avoir des tests fonctionnels
ça fait beaucoup de temps perdu alors
que si le déconfinement avait été gérée
correctement par monsieur jean castex
qui est maintenant premier ministre il
aurait peut-être dû mettre d'abord et
avant tout les tests et s'assurer que la
première dès le premier des réflexes des
français qui avaient des symptômes du
comité c'était de pouvoir être testé
rapidement d'avoir le résultat dans les
48 heures et de pouvoir s'isoler et on
n'en serait pas là aujourd'hui peut-être
donc encore une fois c'est toute cette
chaîne de responsabilité d'organisation
du déconfinement qui a été très mal
faite et qui nous conduit dans cette
deuxième vague parce que manque de
planification manque de stratégie et
aujourd'hui on voit bien il s'agit de
gérer cette deuxième vague
certes mieux qu'au mois de mars mais
avec les moyens du bord
donc avec toujours cette pression
sanitaires sur le nombre de lits en
réanimation
ce risque de ne pas avoir suffisamment
de tests
cette question de de faire appliquer des
mesures difficiles à accepter par les
français comme le couvre-feu est
potentiellement comme un nouveau
confinement
même s'il est localisée alors le
gouvernement qui doit faire donc face à
cette deuxième vague est aussi en
conséquence avec les mesures qui ont été
annoncées à la colère des professionnels
qui sont directement impactés par ce
couvre feu les professionnels notamment
deux de la restauration pour ne citer
qu'eux on a entendu
roselyne bachelot aussi évoqué le
secteur de la culture qui sera
évidemment très impactées qui l'est déjà
et donc il va y avoir un renforcement
des mesures
à tous les niveaux pour ces
professionnels là encore on l'a entendu
jean castex en a entendu
roselyne bachelot mais ça va être quand
même difficile de rassurer ces
professionnels oui parce que aujourd'hui
il ya des mesures de soutien et des
daims à ces secteurs extrêmement impacté
que ce soit la restauration le spectacle
vivant le monde de la nuit en général
mais mais des secteurs entiers qui sont
en train de s'effondrer
le tourisme le transport et plein
d'autres transport aérien notamment
et s'il y a des mesures de soutien
aujourd'hui elles vont avoir une fin
dans le temps on ne voit pas on reste
dans une incertitude totale sur à quand
une reprise d'une vie normale
même avec ce virus sachant que à vaccin
n'est pas pour demain encore une fois
donc les professionnels de ces milieux
là ne sont pas dupes ils savent très
bien que s'il ya des mesures de soutien
ça ne durera qu'un temps
mais pour les patrons de boîtes de nuit
par exemple c'est déjà fini pour
beaucoup impossible de réouvrir mais
même dans les six prochains mois sans
avoir de visibilité sur la réalité d'un
retour à une vie normale une vie sociale
normale donc tous ces métiers d'accueil
tous ces métiers du voyage sont
aujourd'hui dans l'incertitude la plus
totale et si heureusement nous avons des
aides pour les soutenir dans ces moments
là rien ne dit que ce secteur là pourra
se suffire à lui-même et reprendre une
activité normale avant quelques mois
années et entre entre ce moment de
l'aide et ce moment d'un retour à la
normale
c'est là qu'il risque d'y avoir beaucoup
de faillites et une incapacité de retour
à l'activité pour pour beaucoup de ces
entreprises
donc là la réponse elle est celle de
l'urgence c'est normal celle du moyen et
du long terme elles restent à prévoir et
aujourd'hui je pense que les
professionnels de tous ces secteurs ne
voit pas de solution
et évidemment tout le monde est
conscient du coût que cela aurait de dd
de donner une perfusion à des secteurs
entiers pendant des années même si c'est
ce que disait même accro quoi qu'il en
coûte
il va falloir sauver autant
d'entreprises qu'il est possible
alors on va faire bien entendu beaucoup
de dettes on a ce plan de relance
économique mais qui cible aujourd'hui
davantage les grandes entreprises que
ces secteurs impactés même s'ils ont des
aides aujourd'hui donc encore une fois
c'est l'incertitude qui prime et la
certitude ça ne fait jamais bon ménage
avec la croissance économique il faut
aussi préciser que projet de loi pour
prolonger donc l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
jusqu'au 16 février prochain va être
examiné ce week end à l'assemblée avant
de passer au sénat alexis poulain oui il
ya également le fait que nous vivons
donc un moment exceptionnel avec des
lois exceptionnel état d'urgence
sanitaire ça veut dire quoi tout
simplement que le gouvernement peut re
décrété un confinement 1re confinement à
n'importe quel moment
utiliser des mesures contraignantes
passer outre les lois que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui pour imposer ces
mesures contraignantes qui sont encore
une fois difficile à accepter pour
beaucoup de français est difficile à
comprendre comme le disait roselyne
bachelot pour les professionnels de
plein de secteurs qui vivent ça comme
une punition
alors même si jean castex a dit que ce
n'était pas une punition et qui est
c'était malheureusement la seule
solution que le gouvernement avait
trouvé pour limiter les interactions
sociales
il n'empêche que le poids économique est
d'abord répercuter sur ces secteurs qui
sont obligés de fermer à cause du
couvre-feu à cause du confinement ou le
télétravail
rendues difficiles et où de toute façon
l'activité ne peut pas avoir lieu sans
accueil du public
donc tout ça nécessite un temps
d'adaptation est encore une fois
reste à voir quelles vont être les
réponses dans les mois qui viennent une
fois passée la de la deuxième vague le
deuxième pic épidémique
sachant qu'on nous venons n'en voit pas
encore la fin malheureusement ci avoue
alexis poulain un éditorialiste pour
avoir décrypté avec nous donc ces
mesures annoncées aujourd'hui 38
départements supplémentaires et la
polynésie aussi où un couvre feu donc va
débuter vendredi à minuit juste